I've got fundamental disagreements with
you Nicola because in the last couple of
weeks you revealed that you haven't
ruled out having a second referendum on
independence in the next five years now
look we're just very different we've got
very different views and I respect your
views that you want to break up the
country but that's not my view I think
there'll be a disaster for the working
people of Britain so we have profound
differences between us between us David
that's why I'm not going to have a
coalition with the SNP but because I'm
never going to put at risk the unity of
our United Kingdom and why because I
care too much about the working people
of our country and I think it'd be a
disaster for us to start competing
against each other
driving down wages dismantling the basic
state pension which is a foundation of
security in report retirement and
dismantling our country so it's a no I'm
afraid I don't know what Ed Miliband is
talking about the question of
Independence was for the referendum last
year this election is about getting rid
of the Tories and age whatever
differences you have with me Cheerilee
the a does nothing to the differences
both of us have with the Tories this is
about how we deliver better politics for
people not just in Scotland but right
across the UK this